economic stimulus negotiations are
expected to resume today on capitol hill
after months without an agreement house
speaker nancy pelosi says
if there is no deal by tomorrow it will
not happen before election day
nancy cordes has that story from capitol
hill
we have agreement in the language yet
but i'm hopeful
speaker pelosi says she and treasury
secretary steven mnuchin
are still haggling over numbers and the
fine print
they said they changed shell to may
requirements to recommendations a plan
to a strategy not a strategic plan
they took out 55 percent of the language
that we had there for testing and
tracing
in a letter to colleagues on sunday
pelosi said the two sides are also still
at odds
over tax credits for lower income
working people
and funding for state and local
governments she doesn't want to give the
money
after bargaining pelosi down from 3.4
trillion to about two
president trump's story has changed he
now claims
incorrectly that he's the one who wants
a larger deal
we want to do it i want to do it at a
bigger number than she wants
both sides agree the package should
include another round of stimulus checks
money for schools and a reinstatement of
federal unemployment benefits which
lapsed in july
britton foster of new york relied on the
last
stimulus deal basically we've just been
subsisting
at the lowest level that we possibly can
eating as little food as possible
i make sure my daughter has food i eat
once a day
her biggest worry now is losing her home
this is not a political game
it can't wait till after the election it
something has to happen
now one big hit here republicans in the
senate oppose
another big spending bill the republican
leader mitch mcconnell plans to hold an
initial vote tomorrow on a
500 billion dollar stimulus package
that's about a quarter of the size
of the one that's being negotiated
between speaker pelosi
and the white house but democrats
anthony are expected to balk at that
nancy thank you